[Music]
i think the mid-jungle
synergy 400 thieves has been pretty
terrible so when does the squad come in
2 000 health left on baron
can he get it you've got to be kidding
me braxa
comes into the pit grabs the baron they
get two kills over the top
as well 100 thieves had the chance in
their eyes and they've been blinded
i don't think i've ever had a [ __ ] like
a season start this
poorly they're in the pit hundred
thieves aren't contesting this so far
meteos has the ability to jump over the
wall here he tries to go unstoppable but
that was not
it if we don't change and we continue to
work as hard as we are will we make
worlds
and once the answer became no as a
consensus
then changes had to happen turret
destroyed inhibitor destroyed
100 thieves being destroyed
i i don't know if you can have
a good working relationship without
tension after that
because obviously if contracts comes in
and the team gets a lot better than
there's nothing you can even
say it is just disaster into disaster
they've already lost two
despite a respectable spring playoff
finish that came off the back of a
surprising top three regular season
placement meteos and a hundred thieves
this summer
got off to a rough start yeah exactly
what now he's
gonna head straight in there straight
into it meteos is going to get taken
down the red buff comes through very
nicely on that
and that's a kill for jizuke as we say
it he pulls the trigger
right in front of the team of hundred
thieves and picks their pockets
get a bit of a better spot where galio
is roaming down
you've got no one around you to help why
are you challenging an olaf
what was that purpose and now ryoma's
forced to jump away as well but nisky
gets the crowd control
faded in by the hubris of your support
niski though it's going to be a close
fight
gets the taunt gets the hit has to pop
the stopwatch and defend
is there for good measure ensures that
it's another two for
zero and this is going bad to worse 400
thieves
i mean he's really well known as an
excellent team fighter and they are
going for the engage but it's going to
get you oh i'm
talking about cody's son being in a bad
spot and now he's getting himself away
but pobelter's already found the kill on
the meteos and clg will continue
pressuring forward
cody stays back cody stays alive but so
does the entirety of clg
and they'll find two kills it's
frustrating that it feels like we're not
even
agreeing about what we need to change
and so we're not really moving in a
direction we're just kind of
in this limbo 100 thieves were one in
five
after week three with their only win
coming against an immortals roster
that's been since
swapped out completely and things were
only getting worse
no if it's called to try and save him so
it's going to be a five year fourth one
yeah he's trying to end the game right
now he's gonna push the minions in the
other dragon's gonna go over 200 thieves
surely speaker loops in doesn't quite
get it meteor still with the smite is
good a speaker is dead but bjergsen he's
the nexus is there they need to cancel
these backstage trucks he's zipping back
as fast as he possibly can go
burke's in this here he's got the truck
wave again he used it but it takes it
the wrong way but yeah
that's it steals the nexus away from 100
thieves what an
ending falling lower and lower in the
standings hunter thieves knew they
needed to make some big
changes if they hoped to make worlds at
the end of the day it was
guys do we believe and by guys i mean
your stuff do we believe that
if we don't change and we continue to
work as hard as we are because it's
never been a commitment issue
will we make worlds and once the answer
became
no as a consensus then changes had to
happen
and unfortunately for meteos he was
going to be on the receiving end of
those changes
beginning in week four we'll be making
two changes to our starting lcs roster
firstly in the jungle contracts will be
stepping in to replace meteos
we're making a second change at the
support position where academy sport
boom will be promoted to the lcs roster
to replace stun
getting bumped down to academy is
demoralizing for
any lcs player but it stung particularly
deep for meteos as he experienced the
exact same
thing two years ago same split same week
same team benched for full disclosure
like we kind of walked meteos through
our process
he basically accepted it and left
and chose to release his statement which
i think is very much in his right like
from his perspective
it's the same week two years later with
the same org
for him to feel hurt and vulnerable in
that moment and angry and he's a guy who
all year has been like our captain like
he's the guy who's like guys stop
[ __ ] around we need to practice we
need to get on top of this
to be told that he's being removed is
obviously going to be
a huge affront to him meteos was on 100
thieves inaugural lcs roster back when
they first entered the league in 2018.
despite helping them make the finals in
their first ever lcs split
meteos was removed from the starting
lineup after week 3 of the 2018 summer
split
this move came out of left field for two
reasons the first being that a hundred
thieves were coming off a two-and-oh
week things were looking good and the
second part was that meteos seemed
blindsided by this demotion
the community took meteos's side but the
veteran jungler was later traded to
flyquest
where he'd play for their academy squad
as well fans were pissed off with a
hundred thieves of silence on the whole
situation
which is something that nadeshot
addressed months later we felt that a
roster change was necessary
and and and bringing in a new jungler
and removing
meteos that was at the time the best
decision
and i stand by our coaches and i stand
by our management for making that
decision
but where we could have done better with
that entire
transaction was our communication and my
communication
down to my team so coming into 2020 fans
were surprised to see meteos return to a
hundred thieves
but it seemed like him in the org had
moved past the benching
and they even memed on it in their
announcement hey look at us
look at us huh who would have thought
not me
but the meme became a reality once again
as meteos was dropped from 100 thieves
starting roster
three weeks into the summer split and
once he found out
meteos was the first person to break the
news to the world
again this tweet also came out from
meteos after the benching
this is gonna sound like a troll post
but just got word i'm being
benched after week three summer again
not sure why i expected anything
different pretty weird to hear the
players on my team didn't know
about or agree with the decision all
credit goes to zick's law
jungle juice law and papa smithy clearly
the people on the not on the team know
what's best for it i'll just say uh
bang or tweet live evil do that
that'd be my response calling out a
hundred thieves coaching staff in
management in his tweets
meteos just couldn't hold back his
feelings although this time
the community wasn't entirely on his
side the chances of you
being able to play on stage again
does not increase by you
being furious going on twitter
and tagging your coaches telling
the world that you think your coaches
and your staff have absolutely no idea
what they are doing
but what's been worse than the community
backlash to his tweets is the fact that
a hundred thieves has looked
better without him they even went on to
defeat the undefeated cloud nine
and the standout performance from that
win was contract
meteos's replacement what a game from
100 thieves just
dominating start to finish here
contracts
running over his squad from the past
someday a monster on this camille
and they are gonna close it out finally
cloud9 losing and it's on the back of my
boy i've been singing his praises for
such a goddamn long time
juanito arturo garcia better known as
contracts
ran a train using olaf just running over
everybody
this performance today is like whoa you
are rivaling
the kind of smashing games that blabber
does to other kids you made blabber look
like what blabber makes the rest of the
league look like
that is super super important 400
thieves moving forward
a couple of weeks after the benching
meteos parted ways with 100 thieves
and according to the twitlonger he
posted it looks like he's going to be
trying to broaden his future plans
beyond playing professionally but
whether or not we see him back on the
rift
suiting up for the analyst desk or
restarting his stream
we have no doubt that he'll be back
better than ever
because if history has taught lcs fans
anything
it's to never count out videos
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages